nowadays the name tesla has become
ubiquitous for the electric car and
although they definitely did not invent
the technology that itself being at
least 100 years old they are the ones
responsible for making them a feasible
reality this is thanks in large part to
elon musk's dream of making an ev world
and so after decades of building up the
company seems to be fulfilling that
dream quite well with their luxury cars
suvs semis and even the new cyber truck
but the company still seems to be
avoiding one particular market the
public transportation one but that all
changes now as tesla has finally put
forwards their plans to get into the
business particularly with the
development of their own electric van
and being tesla it is sure to be
something special so if you're
interested in that and want to learn
more keep watching this video as we will
tell you everything we know about the
upcoming van from what tesla plans for
it to when we can expect it so without
any further delay let's jump in
one the background although we did
mention that tesla has largely ignored
the large passenger count section of the
market that's not entirely true the
company has in the past hinted toward
that as a possible direction and it
makes sense the entire purpose of evs is
to reduce carbon emissions and public
vehicles make a big part of that from
buses vans delivery trucks and such and
with the global push toward cleaning up
the industrial side of things first it's
no surprise that tesla has had its eye
set on the goal for quite some time old
tesla fans may remember that all the way
back in 2016 in the tesla master plan
part 2 event elon musk talked about two
of the main segments tesla is looking to
electrify
in addition to consumer vehicles there
are two other types of electric vehicles
needed heavy duty trucks and high
passenger density urban transport
immediately the main reaction of the
public was to assume some sort of bus or
van was on its way and what do you know
just a few months later rumors began to
circulate regarding a modified version
of the model x the model x being the
company's large suv that already seats
eight people at max capacity it was no
stretch to think that the company may
find a use for the drivetrain in a
larger vehicle eventually even musk
himself talked about tesla making an
electric minibus based on the model x
before but unfortunately it didn't come
to fruition and that wasn't the only
time tesla flirted with the idea as many
of you may know elon musk is also the
owner of a tunneling company called the
boring company and as these tunnels grew
they needed some vehicles to test run
them with hints already spread regarding
a van it wasn't long before there were
talks about tesla making a van-like
passenger vehicle for musk's boring
company however as time went by it
became increasingly clear that making a
vehicle specifically for the tunnel
making startup was not a good use of
money and so since then the project has
just used existing tesla vehicles for
its transit system and that still wasn't
the last time we got such news as quite
famously in 2018 musk also tweeted in
response to a question that it would be
interesting for tesla to work with
mercedes-benz on an electric version of
their popular and versatile sprinter van
although both companies have confirmed
that such plans were discussed it has
pretty much fizzled down to nothing at
this point two the competition now
another big reason that we think it's
time for tesla to come out with the van
now is the simple fact that the ev world
is not as straightforward as it has been
for a while and companies all around are
pushing toward every niche they can find
and with tesla relatively behind there's
a lot of potential competition that if
not dealt with now might cause problems
down the line as we already mentioned a
potential side to this is the delivery
network of online companies and wouldn't
you know it amazon itself has already
gotten in on the action according to the
company amazon plans to have 10 000 evs
in service by 2022 and for that they've
contracted rivien one of tesla's growing
rivals to deliver 100 000 of these vans
pre-installed with alexa and routing
software over the next few years and
just like online shopping courier
services want a piece of the ev pie like
ups the single biggest one out there has
already ordered 10 000 custom vans from
a british competitor by the name of a
rival to be delivered by 2024. while in
china the famous company byd which has
also made electric buses in the past has
unveiled an all-new electric van with a
125 mile range a top speed of 65 miles
per hour and a charging time from zero
to 100 percent in just two hours at
their high speed terminals the
competition tesla is facing is stiff
three the political scenario
another big contributor to the ev
success in the past has been legislation
that rewards ev owners sometimes via tax
reductions and sometimes just by handing
them money and the electric van market
seems to be getting even more special
treatment with the biden administration
aiming to replace government fleets with
electric vehicles and as a result a
tesla van can make more sense now than
ever add to that the changes in many eu
cities to ban gas vehicles altogether
there's no better time to release
something of this sort 4. the q4
announcement
a few months ago tesla held its
quarterly employee meeting in which a
ton of new things were revealed and one
of them is the reason we're making this
video you see when an employee asked
musk about the prospect of an electric
van this is what he said i think tesla
is definitely going to make an electric
van at some point and that should settle
it already but the company also told
people a ton of other exciting stuff
basically two things make us think that
the company is finally serious namely
what we hear at the conference and
secondly the new self-driving tech and
both of these things tie in perfectly to
the next point five the caveat
now if all of this has been pointing
toward a van where is it well that's
where we run into the same problems as
the tesla semi which although developed
still has to start production as musk
said in his conference the thing to bear
in mind is that there is fundamentally a
constraint on battery cell output if one
is not involved in manufacturing it's
really hard to appreciate just how hard
the scale of production is it's the
hardest thing in the world prototypes
are easy scaling production is very hard
and that's the main reason for the
delays in large-scale vehicles from the
cyber truck to the semi and now the van
however not all hope is lost as there is
one bit of hope
6. the future of tesla
this problem is not a new one and tesla
has already been working on solving the
battery bottleneck for quite some time
and with two special things to help they
might just be rid of all that in the
coming years the first of which is their
new 4680 battery cell with a promised 10
increase in charging times a 16 in range
and a five to six times increase in
power and energy you've got a pretty
serious contender for tesla's next big
thing and what may power the van they
are so confident in this technology
which unlike traditional cells removes
the battery tabs which are the multiple
pieces of conductor that connect a cell
to others by a far more efficient
material and this battery is a direct
result of that in fact they're so
confident in this that they've started a
plan for a sub thirty thousand dollar
car in the near future and the second
factor is well the factories the
gigafactories in texas fremont and
shanghai have all been being built for
quite some time tesla has already said
that they are on target to reach 10
gigawatt hours of production capacity at
their 4680 cell pilot plant in fremont
this year and hope to deploy 100
gigawatt hours of production capacity in
berlin and texas by the end of next year
that my friends is great news as it
means that the van might come very soon
which brings us to the final thing 7.
disabilities and self-driving
by far the biggest reveal in recent
times has been the announcement that not
only do they plan to make it but they
also intend to have it specialized for
people with disabilities and there is a
very specific reason why tesla is the
ideal company to do that and that's
their new self-driving tech for the
longest time the company has been trying
to get a car out there that needs zero
driving input and only recently with the
version 10.1 of their software has the
future looked close they've already
mentioned that they're looking for a car
without a steering wheel and pedals and
so it's not a stretch to think that the
van may not be drivable instead what we
think is that it will act as a
completely autonomous vehicle that will
take up the duties of public
transportation all over the country from
school buses to commute rides and that
my friends is basically the entire story
about this elusive new van from tesla
what do you think about it please feel
free to tell us in the comments thank
you so much for watching and leave a
like if you enjoyed the video and with
that i'll see you next time